If I want to reduce my total supplement load, what can I do?
If I want to reduce my total supplement load, where can I start?
If a person is in complete remission and they're doing really good,
then they can start thinking about possibly cutting back on their supplements.
If your cancer is roaring, then I wouldn't think that way,
but certainly getting another cheek swab is the way to go.
So some people are saying that they can't enter the member site.
But hopefully you guys got a member site, right?
Through the call on the member site, people that are on it right now.
But so really if you want it, if you're concerned about taking too many supplements,
yes, there are, you know, I'm for different times with different people, for different reasons.
I've categorized their supplements, the pond, you know, how, you know, they're,
what's the most important to the least important of their eight supplements or 12 supplements.
I know a lot of people come to us, they're taking a lot of supplements that they were currently on.
And I've said, okay, if you feel like I'm leading to take that supplement, that's just fine.
But make sure you take the ones that tested for you.
There are certainly things that you could possibly drop off over time.
So get to get retested with that request.
We can definitely categorize your supplements to see which ones are more important than others.